(birds chirping)
(soft music)
- My relationship to the natural
world was largely fostered
through my grandparents
who owned a farm in Idaho.
We would go there every summer
and we were free to roam
and play in the forest and hang out.
But I still didn't necessarily think
I wanted to be a scientist.
It wasn't until I got to understand
the creative part of science,
that it wasn't just about memorizing,
like, facts in a text book.
That's what really made me realize,
oh wait, actually this is a
creative process, and I love it.
My name is Kristen Ruegg.
I am an assistant professor
at Colorado State University,
and I am the co-director of a project
called the Bird Genoscape Project.
(soft music)
The goal of the Bird Genoscape Project is
to track hundreds of the most
critically threatened birds.
All kinds of birds are
part of this project
from tiny songbirds, like
the willow flycatcher,
to my favorite, the
charismatic burrowing owl.
I think it's amazing that
over half of the birds
that are in North America actually leave
during the winter months
and go somewhere else
and spend the majority of
the year actually not here.
Birds migrate south in the winter
in search of better weather and more food,
and they migrate back north in the spring
in search of better habitat for breeding.
The main mystery with birds
is where do birds migrate?
The ability to track
migratory birds has been
a huge challenge for centuries.
One of the challenges is
there are tracking devices,
but they're usually not small enough
to be able to put on a migratory bird.
So our thought was, well, if
we could develop a technology
that could use information
within a single feather,
like information in the DNA of the bird
to track their migratory movements,
then we could get
information from every bird
that comes through a monitoring station.
If I wanted to understand
where my ancestors were from,
I might take a DNA sample from me
and send it off to a
genetic ancestry service.
They would compare my DNA
against this huge database
of DNA from many, many other people
and be able to identify
that my most likely ancestry
is largely Norwegian.
In a sense, that's what we're doing
with the DNA found in
a single bird feather.
It's like genetic ancestry
mapping for birds.
So here we have an American robin,
one of our Genoscape species.
This robin, yes, I see you.
This robin migrates from the boreal forest
in Canada and parts of the US
and goes as far south
in the winter as Mexico.
And we also collect the
feathers, the tail feathers,
that we use for genetic analysis.
(uplifting music)
The reason why we collect these feathers
is because we can use the tip
of the feather right here,
which contains a little bit of DNA
to tell you which migratory
pathway this bird took
and where it winters and breeds.
So what you have displayed here
is the map for the Wilson's
Warbler showing the location
of the six populations.
Each one goes to a
different wintering area.
For example, the Rocky
Mountain population heads
all the way down to El
Salvador and Panama.
Using their DNA, we can follow
their migratory journey.
All we need is DNA from
the tip of a feather.
Now that the Bird Genoscape
Project is helping us understand
where and how birds move
throughout the year,
we can figure out the best ways
to help them survive in a changing world.
Uncovering the mysteries of bird migration
may be the key to protecting them.
(uplifting music)